[Musique]
sorte d'emblème religieux la forêt elles
ont droit au xviie siècle où les
personnes ils viennent chercher la
quiétude la solitude l'introspection ou
encore un dialogue avec dieu c'est aussi
le symbole du désert
quel désert le désert de l'egypte dans
lequel au 4e siècle se serait retiré les
premiers grands airs mythes de
l'histoire de l'église occidentale
on n'a pas de désert à se mettre sous la
main et depuis le 14e ou 15e siècle en
europe c'est la forêt qui représente ce
désert
silva et sacra et la forêt des
solitaires est visible jusqu'au 4
juillet au bizet de port royal des
champs une cinquantaine de dessins sont
répartis dans deux salles ils ont été
prêtés par l'albertina devienne la
fondation custodia ou le musée du louvre
pour pouvoir montrer ce désert des
ermites les artistes ont imaginé
plusieurs formes de représentation de la
forêt
ce sont souvent de très grands paysages
soient traités comme les italiens savent
le traité depuis la renaissance soient
traités comme les artistes du nord de
grandes forêts profondes dans lequel on
voit deux petites représentations de
personnages seules vivant dans des
petites cabanes lisent en écrivant ou
travaillant en 1639 antoine lemaitre
grand avocat abandonne son métier décide
de vivre comme un ermite il devient le
premier solitaire de port royal des
champs ce dessin de philippe de
champaigne est réalisée en 1654 pour la
communauté des chartreux c'est un projet
pour un grand tableau d'autel qui
représente saint bruno et les 12
premiers compagnons de saint bruno dans
le massif de la grande chartreuse dans
ce dessein
philippe de champaigne choisi d'utiliser
les méthodes mises au point par martin
devos pour représenter les moines au des
heures dans le cadre de l'exposition une
programmation musicale sera proposée
dimanche 12 juin et dimanche 19 juin à
17 heures à la grange à blé au musée de
port royal des champs